is there some interesting distinction
between physics and math to you
have you looked at physics much to like
speak university of feynman
so
the difference between the physics
community the physics way of thinking
the physics intuition versus
the computer science the theoretical
computer science the mathematical
sciences
do you see that as a gap are they
strongly overlapping
it's quite different
in my opinion i um i started as a
physics major and i switched into math
um and
probably the reason was that i could i
could get a plus on the physics exam but
i like i never had any idea why i would
have been able to
come up with the problems that were on
those exams
but but in math
i i
i i knew
you know why the teacher set those
problems and i thought of other problems
that i could do and i believe it's it's
quite a different mentality
is that it has to do with your
philosophy of geek geekdom
i mean
some of my computer scientists friends
are really good at physics and others
are not and and i i'm
uh you know i'm really good at algebra
but not at geometry you can
talk about different parts of
mathematics you know
so so they're different kind of physical
but physicists think of things in terms
of waves
and
i can think of
things in terms of waves but it's like a
dog walking on hind legs if i'm thinking
about it so you basically you like to
see the world in in uh
in discrete ways and then because it's
more continuous yeah i i i'm not sure
if turing would have been a great
physicist i
think it was a pretty good
chemist
i don't know but but uh but anyway i see
things
i i i believe that computer science is
largely
driven by uh
people who have
brains who
who are good at
resonating with
certain kind of
of of concepts
and like quantum computers it takes a
different kind of brain yeah that's
interesting yeah
it's well quantum computers is almost
like at the intersection in terms of
brain
uh between computer science and physics
because they it involves both at least
at this at this time
um but there is like the physicists i've
known
they have incredibly powerful intuition
and and there's i mean statistical
mechanics so i i study
uh statistical mechanics and
you know
i mean random processes uh uh are
related to algorithms in a lot of a lot
of ways and so but there's lots of
different flavors of flavors of physics
as there are different flavors of
mathematics as well
um but but the thing is that i i don't
see
well
actually when they talk to physicists
use completely different language than
when they're talking to
when they're writing expository papers
so i didn't understand quantum mechanics
at all from reading about it in
scientific american
but but when i read
you know how they described it to each
other talking about eigen eigenvalues
and
and various mathematical
terms that
that made sense
then it made sense to me but but but
hawking said that
every formula you put in a book you lose
half of your readers and so he didn't
put any formulas in the book so i
couldn't understand his book at all
you could say you understood it but
i really
i really didn't
um well feynman
also spoke in this way so feynman
i think prided himself on really strong
intuition but at the same time he was
hiding all the the really good the the
deep computation he was doing so so
there was one thing that that uh
that i i was never able to uh yeah i
wish i'd had more time to work out with
him but i guess i could describe it for
you there's
there's something that got my name
attached to it
called knuth arrow notation but it's a
notation for very large numbers and so
uh it it i find out that that
somebody invented it in in 1830s uh it's
fairly easy to
to understand anyway so you start with
x
plus x plus x plus x
n times
and and you can call that x n
so x n is multiplication then you take x
times x
times x times x and n time that gives
you
exponentiation x to the nth power
so that's one arrow x
so x n with no arrows is multiplication
x
arrow n is x to the nth power yes just
to clarify for the uh
so x times x times x and times is
obviously x n
x
x plus x plus x n times n
oh yeah okay and then uh x n
multiplication is x to the n uh and then
and then here the arrow is when you're
doing the same kind of repetitive
operation for the exponential so i so i
put in one arrow and i get x to the nth
power now i put in two arrows and that
makes takes x to the x to the x to the x
to the x
n times pi
so in other words if if
if if it's two
uh
double arrow
uh three that would be
that would be 2 to the 2 to the 2
so that would be 2 to the fourth power
that'd be 16 okay okay so so so that's
the double arrow
and now you can
do
triple arrow
of course uh and
and and so on
and
and i i had this this paper called
uh well
essentially big numbers
uh
you know you yeah you try to impress
your friend but by saying a number
they've never thought of before yeah and
and
and i i gave a special name
for it
we
designed a font for it that has script k
and so on but it but it really is 10 i
think like 10
quadruple aero 3 or something like that
and i claim that that number if
it is so mind-boggling that you can't
comprehend how large it is
but anyway fine
i talked to feynman about this and he
said oh
let's just let's just use double arrow
but instead of taking integers let's
consider
complex numbers so
you know you have d
i mean okay x x arrow arrow 2 that means
x to the x
x but what about x
x double arrow 2
2.5 well that's not too hard to figure
out that's interpolate between those but
what what what
x double arrow
i or one plus i or some complex number
uh
and
and uh so he claimed that
that that that there was no analytic
function that would
that would do that would do the job uh
but i i i i didn't know how he could
claim that that was that wasn't true
and his next question was did then have
a complex number of arrows
[Laughter]
yeah okay wow okay okay so so that's
that that's fine when uh that's fine
you